in 1996 twister stormed its way to
Blockbuster status directed by action
movies stalwart John Devon twister
depicts a team of University scientists
led by Dr Joe Harding played by Helen
Hunt as they try to put a data Gathering
device to work during an onslaught of
tornadoes she's forced to team up with
her ex-husband played by Bill Paxton to
get everything operational especially
when they're sneering rival Dr Jonas
Miller plans to use a device he built
himself twister picked up
241.7 million dollars at the box office
so a sequel makes sense in October 2022
deadline reported that legendary
filmmaker and amblin entertainment boss
Steven Spielberg loved a script written
by Mark L Smith and put the film into
pre-production producers are hoping to
sign Helen Hunt as the plot of the
sequel currently titled Twisters will
emphasize her relationship with her
daughter whose father was the character
portrayed by Paxton who died in 2017.
the film will Roar into theaters on July
19 2024.